et je le disais tout à l'heure janvier
c'est la période traditionnelle pour
présenter ses vœux plusieurs communes
d'ailleurs de 50 ans en Yvelines des
Yvelines mais aussi de toute la France
organise leur cérémonie pour souhaiter
une bonne année alors habitants et tout
au long du mois de janvier télé 78
reçoit les maires des communes de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pour parler
des grands projets de 2023 dans leur
ville Nicolas Dainville voilà vous avez
switché de place vous êtes passé de
l'autre côté vous inaugurez ce tour
d'horizon des mers de Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines je le rappelle Edil de la
commune de La Verrière vous êtes
également vice-président de
l'agglomération de 50 ans en Yvelines et
du département des Yvelines alors en ce
début d'année le mot aussi qui revient
dans toutes les bouches c'est celui de
la sobriété énergétique qu'est-ce qui a
été fait dans la ville de La Verrière
qu'est-ce qui a été fait déjà en 2022 et
qu'est-ce que vous prévoyez de faire
justement en 2023 pour aller vers plus
d'économies ben écoutez déjà un chiffre
c'est vrai que la facture de gaz pour la
ville de La Verrière c'est multiplié par
5 donc c'est des coûts qui explosent qui
nous oblige effectivement à des vrais
efforts on a baissé la température nos
équipements publics on s'est mis sur les
recommandations de de l'État on a
également entreprises un remplacement de
notre éclairage avec plus de LED on a
malheureusement à contrecoeur vraiment
drastiquement diminué nos illuminations
de Noël on a transformé notre concours
d'illumination au concours de décoration
on a lancé des audits énergétiques pour
essayer de de mieux consommer
et puis on investit sur l'avenir
notamment avec les quartiers qu'on va
essayer de réhabiliter de manière
ambitieuse pour qu'il y ait des
meilleurs isolations des meilleurs
consommations pour que ça soit aux
normes environnementales les plus
modernes les plus innovantes monsieur
justement dans la vidéo de présentation
de vos vœux vous en avez fait une en
avant première parce que veut officiels
ce sera ce vendredi au scarabée vous
avez parlé des habitants notamment du
bois de l'étang qui était durement
touchés par la hausse des charges
comment la ville peut les accompagner en
allant vers plus de rénovation
énergétique en les accompagnant sur sur
ce sujet exactement ça a été assez
terrible pour pour les habitants du bois
de l'étang qu'on vus leur facture
parfois multiplier par trois leur charge
qui ont donc brutalement et massivement
augmenté la ville a accompagné les
familles les plus fragilisées avec notre
CCAS pour les accompagner à mobiliser
les aides auxquelles ils ont le droit
pour les aider pour vraiment ceux qui
étaient les plus en précarité mais
effectivement sur le long terme il faut
vraiment réhabiliter les logements pour
consommer mieux consommer moins et donc
c'est toute l'ambition de notre projet
avec l'enru l'Agence nationale de
rénovation urbaine c'est près de 80
millions d'euros qui vont être investis
sur le courtier de réalisation c'est
sans précédent dans ces 80 millions il y
a la nouvelle école il y a la nouvelle
maison de quartier il y a les voiries si
on parle de rénovation de démolition de
logement mais aussi de mise en place de
nouveaux services également exactement
la démolition de logement c'est 212
logements démoli et plus de 400
puissamment réhabilités sur les
installations électriques sur les
sanitaires sur les canalisations sur
l'isolation thermique sur système de
chauffage qui va permettre justement de
consommer mieux sur l'aspect extérieur
également pour changer l'image de
quartier pour améliorer l'attractivité
il y aura même une formule urbaine avec
des couronnes sur les toitures pour
avoir une vision du quartier au loin qui
soit très moderne l'idée c'est pas de se
dire c'est tout on était réhabilités
c'est qu'on ait l'impression que ce sont
des nouvelles tours modernes casser
aussi le côté grand ensemble pour
résidentialiser améliorer le
stationnement bref c'est un quartier
pour qui va changer pour améliorer la
qualité de vie est-ce que les travaux
ont déjà démarré ce que ça va être le
cas cette année alors là le diagnostic
va progressivement prendre fin les
travaux vont commencer dans l'année qui
vient c'est des travaux qui s'étale sur
plusieurs années puisque les travaux
n'ont par logement sont quand même assez
puissants
on parle à peu près de 65000 euros par
logement c'est le ratio donc c'est quand
même un ratio important
sans précédent comme je automatisé donc
c'est effectivement un des projets
essentiels au projet du siècle comme
jamais à le dire pour la verrière qui va
rentrer dans une phase très concrète là
dans quelques mois pour le quartier
d'Orly Park aussi les choses bougent en
2023 bah exactement on a terminé nos
aménagements extérieurs dont on est
assez fier et que l'équipe on voulait un
effet waouh pour vraiment avoir le
meilleur en terme d'équipement avec des
aires de jeux le boulot de Drôme le
street workout mis à la fois sur le
sport et sur des espaces de convivialité
on a des tables de jeu d'échec par
exemple voilà maintenant il y a toute la
partie réhabilitation des logements qui
se précisent avec le bailleur pour
essayer aussi de d'améliorer certaines
difficultés notamment en termes
d'humidité qui se pose encore dans
beaucoup de logements mais je dirais que
sur Orly park on a quand même un nouveau
souffle une nouvelle dynamique qui a pu
s'enclencher on en parlait aussi sur ce
plateau il y a quelques semaines c'est
aussi tout le quartier autour de la gare
qui va être en mutation et les travaux
d'aménagement ça ça déjà démarré qui
sont en cours sur le Polgar ça se
poursuit aussi dans les années à venir
avec le projet de futur écoquartiers
garbecane alors dès cette année il y a
un nouveau parking qui est en cours de
construction notamment dans cette cet
espace gare ce Polgar exactement le
nouveau parking va ouvrir la dans
quelques semaines c'est 914 places pour
être précis avec une autoconsommation
donc des panneaux photovoltaïques qui
vont permettre à ce parking de
fonctionner de manière autonome et ça va
surtout permettre de dégager de
l'emprise au sol pour avoir un grand
parvis piéton et végétalisé qui va
améliorer
l'accessibilité pour les piétons avec
une rampe d'accès aussi pour les
personnes mobilité réduite qui va être
vraiment améliorée c'est un gros dossier
dont la ville ne maîtrise pas l'ensemble
des tenants et des aboutissants c'est
nos partenaires qui investissent
puissamment je pense à Saint-Quentin je
pense au département il y a la région
mais ça va vraiment permettre d'avoir un
vrai quartier de la gare ce qui manquait
aujourd'hui et notamment sur la partie
avec ce fameux parvis et cette offre de
commerce qui devrait également être
amélioré alors dès cette année aussi ça
fait partie des gros projets il y a un
poste de police municipale qui est mise
en place exactement il est déjà ouvert
il a déjà inauguré c'était effectivement
une de des ambitions de notre de notre
équipe d'avoir une police municipale
renforcée donc on a trois agents ils ont
des vélos ils ont également des armes
des armes non létales mais des teasers
pour ne pas les citer qui vont permettre
voilà de de mener des opérations
notamment de sécurité routière en toute
sécurité et ils sont accompagnés d'une
équipe de médiateurs c'était aussi une
des grandes ambitions on en parlait sur
ce plateau pendant la campagne
électorale c'est vrai que l'équipe
précédente n'avait pas réussi à avoir
les les financements de l'État pour
avoir les deux médiateurs qui auraient
pourtant eu le droit et là on a
maintenant une équipe de cinq médiateurs
donc 4 sont financés par l'État pour la
tranquillité publique pour arpenter nos
rues parler avec nos jeunes des lancer
des conflits et veiller à la
tranquillité dans la rue alors je le
cite parce que vous en parlez également
dans cette vidéo qui a retrouvé sur le
site de La Verrière ou par le site du
déploiement des tablettes qui va se
poursuivre avec des écoliers de
primaires qui sont concernés des projets
culturels également qui sont menés avec
la file harmonie de Paris avec le Centre
de Musique Baroque de Versailles on
parle de démos on aura un reportage à
voir dans un instant et également donc
le projet ville baroque qui est mené
mais le rendez-vous dont on parlait il y
a un instant nickel qui est toujours
avec nous en plateau rendez-vous à ne
pas manquer c'est ce Paris-Nice cette
81e édition du Paris-Nice la Course au
Soleil s'élancera le 5 mars depuis la
verrière
alors si j'ai bien compris le village
départ sera au niveau du du parc
Philippe Cousteau c'est bien ça si je me
suis pas trompé le dps devant la mairie
devant la mairie c'est un événement mais
le bilan le village effectivement sera
au parc Philippe Cousteau c'est un
événement historique pour une petite
commune comme la nôtre c'est près de 8
millions de téléspectateurs qu'on les
arrivé sur la verrière donc un coup de
projecteur hors norme c'est une vraie
fierté parce que ça va renforcer le
sentiment d'appartenance à la ville ça
permet de rayonner de parler de
patrimoine trop souvent méconnu je pense
notamment à notre beau château jardin
dessiné par Le Nôtre toute l'histoire de
ce château incroyable avec le compte de
la Valette qui était l'aide de quand de
Bonaparte donc ça va vraiment être un
événement je dirais sans précédent
historique hors norme et on est associé
avec le Mesnil-Saint-Denis puisque donc
les coureurs s'élancent de la mairie
vont ensuite passer dans la gare
remonter sur l'avenue de Montfort
parcourir le Mesnil les 17 tournants la
vallée de Chevreuse repasser une seconde
fois dans la verrière et terminer sur la
grande avenue du Général Leclerc au
niveau de la rue Henriette sur la
commune du Mesnil-Saint-Denis pour un
sprint pour un sprint c'est vrai qu'il y
aura les meilleurs coureurs de la de la
planète tu auras le vainqueur du Tour de
France donc pour ceux qui aiment le vélo
qui aime je dirais ces très bon
planétaire c'est un engouement populaire
assez extraordinaire et on aurait
effectivement aussi une occasion d'avoir
un événement de convivialité avec nos
associations donc sur ce parc Philippe
Cousteau les associations de nos deux
communes Mesnil-Saint-Denis la verrière
qui sont sollicités vous savez à peu
près combien il y aura de personnes de
visiteurs sur la verrière pendant le
Paris-Nice alors une chose est sûre ça
sera un grand bazar en termes de
circulation mais on va travailler avec
le département pour tout ce qui est
barrière âge avec amoris pour
organisation pour la partie parcours
également avec Saint-Quentin qui va nous
aider sur le sur les parkings
stationnement j'ai pas de chiffres
précis à vous communiquer et sont des
milliers mais plusieurs milliers de
personnes voilà moi j'étais allé à
Mantes-la-Ville pour le départ de
l'année dernière et c'est vrai que
c'était plusieurs milliers de personnes
et avec un public très familial très
passionné qui vient de loin et et avec
un sport qui n'a pas encore pris la
mauvaise tournure du sport business
comme dans le football
c'est à dire qu'il y a des échanges
possibles avec les joueurs il est
coureurs avec les équipes et c'est ça
qui est assez extraordinaire dans le
vélo très rapidement un rassemblement
City rassemble justement cette
libérations les passionnés celui de des
Mustang il avait été annulé à cause de
la crise carburant il y aura bien lieu
au printemps finalement il a été déposé
oui oui on va le déplacer au mois de
juin au mois de juin c'est un événement
qui permet la vie de rayonner sur une
thématique atypique on veut être la
capitale francilienne de la Mustang
c'est un événement de passionné c'est
pas du tout un des voitures bling bling
comme d'autres marques qu'on ne citera
pas c'est au contraire des voitures qui
symbolisent la liberté qui sont
mythiques avec des passionnés qui ont
envie de partager cette passion et qui
permettent de récolter de l'argent pour
les associations c'est les restos du
cœur la dernière fois il y aura d'autres
associations qui seront sélectionnées
pour ce weekend de juin ou le
l'événement sera organisé et pour
terminer cet entretien l'interview
express
[Musique]
le principe Nicolas David je vais vous
poser cinq questions à nous poserons les
mêmes à tous les maires qui viendront
sur notre plateau en janvier une
exigence des réponses courtes certaines
nécessitent un oui ou un nom un pour ou
contre donc ça c'est très facile ou les
autres pour celles qui demandent un peu
plus explications je vais vous demander
de répondre en 20 secondes maximum alors
la première question est-ce qu'en 2023
vous augmenterez les impôts locaux dans
votre commune réponse non c'est pas du
tout prévu même si je dois quand même
souligner une grande incertitude
budgétaire puisque la ville de La
Verrière je le rappelle souvent c'est
72% de logements sociaux donc on est une
ville dépendante de tous nos partenaires
et les dotations de l'État et de nos
partenaires ont tendance plutôt à fondre
comme neige au soleil donc pas
d'augmentation d'impôts prévues mais une
grande rigueur sur les services sur le
le fonctionnement mais c'est la
certitude pour pour les autres années en
tout cas pour cette année aucune
augmentation d'un pot de prévu alors
côté circulation certaines communes ont
fait le de passer de limiter leur
vitesse dans la commune à 30 km/h ce que
vous êtes pour ou contre une telle
mesure je trouve ça très intéressant
pour la commune de La Verrière la
décision n'est pas prise on a des
réflexions qui sont menées sur le
stationnement avec des zones bleues
notamment pour certains parkings sur la
circulation notamment sur les pistes
cyclables ou avec l'agglo il faut qu'on
se positionne très vite pour voir les
rues qui vont pouvoir accueillir des
pistes
pour l'instant pas de décision prise sur
les 30 km/h mais en tout cas une
incitation avec la police municipale
vraiment réduire drastiquement la
vitesse si on est route pour ou contre
l'obligation du bio dans les cantines
pour une incitation ça c'est dans le cas
de nos clients
pas d'obligation en tout cas avec notre
prestataire on va vraiment
répondre à l'exigence de l'État après
qui dit bio dit coup supérieur donc
voilà il faut qu'on soit toujours dans
l'équilibre entre un coup supportable
pour la mairie pour les familles on a
des familles qui n'ont pas toujours les
les finances illimitées et une exigence
de qualité le biomé aussi des circuits
courts et ça va être toute l'ambition
pour le projet Gard bécane d'améliorer
notamment les circuits courts sur les
terrains qui seront exploités par une
agriculture de proximité on a vu
malheureusement dans les derniers mois
des mers qui ont été victimes des élus
d'agressions ou de menaces est-ce que
dans l'exercice de vos fonctions vous
avez déjà eu peur physiquement la
réponse est oui je crois que le chiffre
c'est 1300 agressions sur les élus en
2019 ou 2020 et je crois que c'est
quasiment trois fois plus que l'année
recours quand on a un problème ou quand
on a un projet et le dernier recours
quand on a un problème on est la
relation de ceux qui n'en n'ont pas et
ça donne c'est une vraie exigence et
c'est un vrai bonheur d'essayer autant
de faire ce peu d'aider concrètement les
gens qu'on a besoin et ça bien plus beau
bonheur que d'essayer d'aider les autres
merci Nicolas Dainville maire de la
commune de La Verrière très bonne année
2023 merci beaucoup